uh I'm gonna get you caught up on what
it was it's of course the theme for
today's program uh Joe Rogan got into it
on Twitter uh with this guy Dr Peter
hotez now Dr Peter Hotes has been a
proponent of vaccines for many many
years he's written books about vaccines
he's been on Rogan's program a couple
times and he went after Rogan on Twitter
for having Robert F Kennedy Jr on his
show now we showed you some clips of RFK
Jr on Rogan's show last week and RFK Jr
of course he's fighting pharmaceutical
companies and the vaccine makers uh he's
really doing a lot of things basically
just by being a roughly sane person that
put him outside of what the mainstream
Overton window is but also really out
outside of what the Democrats can accept
so anyway hotels went after Rogan even
though he's been on Rogan's show several
times for having someone that he
disagrees with RFK on the show and
basically was calling for Spotify to
give Rogan the boot over misinformation
and then all hell broke loose on Twitter
Elon Musk got involved Andrew Tate got
involved millions of dollars were raised
to a well were potentially raised so
that these guys would have a debate
we'll see what happened I got in the mix
of it it was it was wacky it was wild it
actually made the internet fun for a
brief moment but the reason I want to
cover it today and why we're framing the
show around it is because what do I tell
you guys all the time the truth is a
Time release pill and what is happening
more and more and more these days is as
more people wake up to reality as the
sensorious machine loses some degree of
control by say Elon Musk having Twitter
and people being able to share their
thoughts and all of that kind of stuff
and Rumble being out there and
everything else that time release pill
which used to be like years right like
they could lie and it would take us
years to debunk it's that window is
getting shorter and shorter and shorter
and the shorter it gets the crazier
everyone gets it's because it's lie
debunk lie debunk lie debunk as opposed
to oh that thing happened a while ago
now we kind of know the truth it's
happening in real time now and I think
there's uh there's something something
Bruin that might actually be good so
anywho that is what we will be talking
about today but first I want to talk to
you people about meat uh do you guys
know that 60 of U.S pork production
comes from one company owned by the
Chinese I know you know that and their
Hogs are given something called
ractopamine which is banned in 160
countries including China yet you find
it in your grocery aisle every day guys
there's a better way I want to tell you
about moink that is Moo plus oink moink
delivers grass-fed and grass-finished
beef and lamb pastured pork and chicken
and sustainable wild caught Alaskan
salmon straight to your door you choose
the meat delivered in every box like rib
eyes to chicken breasts to pork chops to
salmon fillets and much more you can
cancel any time and I gotta tell you
there is nothing better than cooking my
Meats on the Big Green Egg on a Friday
evening Shark Tank host Kevin O'Leary
called moink's bacon the best Bay bacon
he's ever tasted and they guarantee
you'll say oink oink I'm just so happy I
got moist keep American farming going by
signing up at moinkbox.com Ruben right
now and listeners of this show get a
free filet mignon in every order for a
year that's one of the best filet mignon
you'll ever taste but for a limited time
m-o-i-n-kbox.com
reubenmoinkbox.com Reuben and now back
to me I felt that was a particularly
good read today for the moink Box all
right
so let's talk about this Rogan hotels
RFK brouhaha we will start with a clip
from RFK Jr on Joe Rogan's show last
week talking about how Pfizer and big
Pharma deceives the public and did a
particularly nasty job of doing that
when it came to the covid vaccine which
they told us was safe and effective wink
wink
the description of why the coveted
vaccines were a hundred percent
effective
and what they used to make that
distinction it's not no it like explain
that explain that because it's such a
bizarre
the way they do it it seems like it
should be illegal what they did
with the covet vaccine is they they gave
the covet this is the Pfizer trial we
know a lot about the Pfizer trial
because that was the one that was Pfizer
was the one to get an approved vaccine
you know it got the it did another trick
it got one of its vaccines approved the
pulmonary vaccine but that vaccine was
not available in this country
but they were able to say to people oh
we haven't approved vaccine and that
made it okay for the colleges and
everybody else to force you to take an
emergency use authorization vaccine
which is illegal nobody can tell you to
participate in that medical experiment
what they did is they had 22 000 people
got the vaccine 22 000 have done it and
they have the six months of data some of
that is unblinded but it's six months
and during that six-month period in the
vaccine group one person died of covet
and in the placebo group two people died
from coven
so that allows Pfizer to tell the public
and you know FDA to tell the public oh
this vaccine is 100 effective because
two is a hundred percent of one
okay now before I do anything else in
today's show I am not going to sit here
and tell you that I know for a fact that
everything that RFK laid out in that
interview is completely true uh I think
he has a really good handle on this
stuff and we were doing a little
background research we couldn't straight
up debunk anything he said but that is
the point of interviews and counter
interviews and debate which really is
what sort of broke loose this weekend
when Rogan will get to it in a moment
offered hotels to debate RFK Jr but a
couple points that he made there that
are worth repeating and really diving
into first off the idea that Pfizer got
immunity meaning you cannot Sue visor
visor they got immunity for a vaccine
that did not give you immunity right so
the vaccine was sold remember Joe Biden
if you get this vaccine you will not get
or transmit kovid remember Rachel Maddow
we played that video last week just
lying repeatedly everyone everyone from
the machine
they did not know what they were talking
about or they knowingly lied and why is
it that the wool got pulled over their
eyes or they knowingly lied why didn't
that happen to me why I'm on air every
day right why did I not fall for it some
people did not we we were all pushed to
the side but some people were all in on
it hook line and sinker or confused by
it or tricked up by it or whatever else
but the point is Pfizer itself got
immunity for a vaccine that did not
offer you immunity through a trial that
went for six months right and on top of
the fact that through warp speed it was
all pushed through very fast right
that's something that Trump is going to
have a have to have a Reckoning with one
day so that's one thing so emergency use
and warp speed and the fact that it
wasn't tested long term because they
pushed it through so how would they know
what was really going to happen and what
all the vaccine injuries were going to
be and what the efficacy was and
everything else if you remember the
three crazy years of covid it was like
every week once once we really started
realizing that that the vaccines weren't
working every week it was like okay it's
100 effective it's 97 effective this
week it's 82 percent oh 54 13 no I'm not
sure if it's working at all hot diggity
dog
you also have to remember and he
mentions this there that this mRNA
technology had never been used like this
before right gain of function research
where you take one virus and you mutate
it you gain a function of it a virus has
a function you now gain a function so
you do something new to it all together
and then we just decided to inject this
into hundreds of millions of people all
over the globe I did not get vaccinated
my blood is pure your blood's pure your
blood's poor your blood's pure you guys
want to go have blood Purity party later
anyway uh questioning and this is what
this is really all about questioning all
of this stuff talking about the
motivations of Pfizer and the and the
motivations of the government and the
media and all that stuff that's what
this is really about that's really what
RFK is doing here he also went further
on here we'll show clip number two to
explain to Rogan how the vaccine
companies still profit off vaccines that
they were pushing even in the 80s take a
look
because Reagan caved in and it wasn't
just Reagan it was the Democrats my
uncle was chairing the health committee
at that time and the Democrats also went
along
they passed the vaccine act in 1986 and
the vaccine act gave immunity from
liability to all vaccine companies if
you for any injury for negligence
no matter how negligent you are no
matter how Reckless your conduct no
matter how toxic the ingredient how
shortly tested or manufactured the
product no matter how Grievous your
entry you your vaccine company you
cannot be sued
so if this was a huge gift for this
industry because the the biggest cost
for every medical product is Downstream
liabilities
and all of a sudden those disappeared so
you're not only taking away that cost
but you're always and incentivizing the
production of many new vaccines
you're also
disincentivizing you're removing the
incentive to to make them safe because
they're no matter how dangerous there
are they don't care because they can't
be sued
and then but you may say well if they
really dangerous then uh nobody's going
to buy them but the problem with that is
nobody has a choice
they not only got rid of the the
downstream liability but they don't have
any advertising or marketing costs
because the federal government is
ordering 76 million people it's
essentially ordering 76 million kids to
take the product a year
if you can get that on the schedule it's
like renting a billion dollars for you
okay so he's calling out both sides with
this 86 Bill signed by Reagan and pushed
through by the Democrats so that that is
interesting right this was sort of
bipartisan That vaccine companies Pharma
companies were not going to be liable
and then he's making a great Point once
you get rid of the liability the
companies are going to do all sorts of
things right there's going to be all
sorts of sorts of fudges with the
research and the science because they
just want to get stuff to Market because
they want to make money that is how it
works so you say to them push it out as
fast as possible and then it's kind of
beautiful when it comes to something
like Ovid because even if people don't
want to take it we will work with
corporations to force people to take it
so you remember that OSHA mandate if you
were a company of over a thousand was it
over a thousand people or over a hundred
people do you remember
it was a hundred people if it was if you
had a company that was over a hundred
people they could force you to force
your employees to take the covid vaccine
so we're going to take away the uh the
liability so God only knows what's in
this and we're gonna Force you
people to take it and we're going to
make sure that kids have to take it to
get into school get into college and
everything else I mean what a freaking
bracket now speaking of rackets there
were some people all along the way uh
that were not
trying to convince people to take
vaccines that were basically saying I
think I'm pretty sure you will not find
one video of me saying anything other
than you should do what you think is
right for you you have to think about
your age and your weight and how much
risk you want to take and do you have
any other comorbidities and all of those
things you may remember that at one
point Joe Rogan said on his show that he
took Ivermectin and he was told and
mainstream media went bananas with it
that Joe Rogan was taking horse dewormer
to stop himself from taking covet and
he's killing people because other people
will take horse dewormer for getting rid
of kovid Rogan mentioned that's RFK as
well
how it actually works how the system
actually works to go against people that
are dissenters I have no questions
because I was in the middle of it I saw
it I saw it happen I saw the CNN thing
where they made my face yellow and said
I was taking horse medication which is
that the most it's to say that and
repeat that over and over again is such
a clear indication that they conspired
it's such a because this it's uniform
it's horse dewormer uniform a medication
that's used far more often on human
beings it's been prescribed for billions
yeah it's insane and the fact that and
won the Nobel Prize for for efficacy in
humans yeah in humans yeah it was wild
it was just wild they had to do it
they had to discredit Ivermectin because
you know because there's a federal law
the federal law the emergency use
authorization statute says that you
cannot issue you cannot issue an
emergency use authorization to a vaccine
if there is an existing medication that
has been approved for any purpose
that has demonstrated effective against
the target illness
so they had to destroy Ivermectin and
hydroxyl organs and discredit and they
had to tell everybody it's not effective
because if they had acknowledged that
it's effective in anybody
the whole 200 billion dollar vaccine
Enterprise would have collapsed
looking back guys and now connecting the
dots doesn't this all make sense now
that you know that what RFK just said
right there which is true when they do
these emergency authorizations if
anything else is out there that is
proven to work against what they're
going for the Emergency authorization on
they can't do the emergency
authorization now there's a whole bunch
of money tied up in Pfizer and
everything else right Johnson and
Johnson even they weren't doing mRNA
technology moderna et cetera they want
the government to use emergency
authorization knowing they have no
liability uh they want to get it in as
many arms as possible and I guess
they'll they'll see what happens after
but that explains do you remember that
do you remember that time we we
definitely covered it on the show when
Rogan was talking about it and they're
literally on CNN saying Rogan's going to
kill people anyone who talks about
Ivermectin was getting booted off
Twitter and off Facebook well-known
doctors were being kicked off all of
these things just for saying hey guys
maybe you actually don't have to take
this experimental MRI RNA vaccine maybe
there's some other ways to deal with
this and now you understand why because
literally had that gotten out had more
people got into critical mass on that
there were alternative ways to deal with
covid
maybe a little sunlight maybe just
eating right maybe not being obese Etc
et cetera then they would not have been
able to push it out and get that vaccine
into everybody's Arms by the way uh just
FYI I took Ivermectin when we got to
Florida I got to Florida I'll never
forget the day December 17 2021 I tested
positive for covid the next day so I
must have had it in LA David tested
positive I think Clyde was okay but we
both tested positive we got Ivermectin
that day and for me with covid my legs
hurt for about three days that was it I
was outside playing ball walking the dog
doing everything else David was a little
more sick but the point is uh I was not
taking horse dewormer it is that is one
of the uses for it but it's also used in
Africa to get rid of all sorts of
diseases but okay so be it what gets us
to what happened to this weekend well uh
RFK uh mentioned uh to Joe Rogan that
vaccinologist that's an actual word
scientician and vaccinologist Peter
Hotes refuses to debate him now and
Peter hotez is a doctor who has pushed
vaccines he's written books about
vaccines he was pushing the coveted
vaccine and he has been on Rogan's show
many times so Rogan was interested in
was interested in hey why don't you guys
chat there you go
have you had anyone debate you publicly
about any of these nobody will debate me
for 18 years no but he will debate me in
fact
I've scheduled many many debates and
I've asked hotels
many many times to debate me and I think
you've asked him here why don't you
debate Robert Kennedy and he said
because he said cunning lawyer or
something like that but um yeah but I've
made it I hope it's on the telephone
with uh you know with kind of a referee
and you know I his his science is is is
just made up he cannot stand by it he
can't cite studies well he was trying to
tell me that vaccines don't cause autism
okay so Peter hotez again he's been on
Rogan a couple times he actually wrote a
book about how vaccines do not cause
autism because his daughter has autism
and was vax and then he wrote a whole
book about how it had nothing to do with
each other now that's separate from the
coveted vaccine specifically uh but
let's dive into a little bit more about
who Peter Hotes is and how this debate
then turned so hot over the weekend but
before we do that let me talk to you
guys about home title lock uh guys the
deed to our homes is the only document
that proves you own it the problem is
the Deeds to all our homes are online
right now a criminal confined Forge your
signature and refile as the new owner of
your home then they'll take out loans
using your home's equity and leave you
in debt you won't know until collection
notices show up on loans that you never
took out homeowners insurance doesn't
cover you and neither the common
identity theft programs home title lock
is your peace of mind that the deed to
your home is protected go to
hometidalock.com Dave and use promo code
Dave enter your address for a no
obligation home title scan to see if
you're already a victim that's a hundred
dollar value absolutely free be sure to
use my promo code Dave for your free
title scan at home home title lock.com
Dave promo code Dave okay
so who is Dr Peter Hotes well he's a
vaccine scientist he's an author and he
combats this is according to his own bio
he combats anti-science uh no sorry I'll
read it straight up vaccine scientist
author combat anti-science and professor
of Pediatrics molecular virology okay
that's a lot of words the guy's got a
pedigree okay that's nice now as I said
he has been on Rogan twice both times
during covid discussing covet discussing
vaccines
etc etc uh in this first clip we're
going to show you Rogan did Grill him a
bit when it came to pushing vaccines and
General Health and diet vitamins and
everything else because Rogan was to his
credit always somewhat skeptical about
all of this stuff
do you take care of your immune system
in other ways do you take probiotics are
you cautious about your diet
um I'm not as cautious about my diet as
I should be I'm a junk food-aholic uh
actually well that seems like a terrible
thing for your health it is a terrible
thing for my health and something my
wife is working on it but that seems
ridiculous for someone who works with
health yeah yeah
sometimes man I just don't get it right
do you take vitamins I don't take
vitamins really yeah wow I think they do
I don't think they're neither because
most in the American and the American up
hold up hold up you don't think they're
needed while you're eating junk food
well hopefully I'm not only eating junk
food but you know there's a large body
of clinical research on the efficacy of
vitamins especially vitamins D vitamins
I have taken vitamin D for periods and
the recommendation of my internist and
what about essential fatty acids which
are great for your brain fish oil all
these different things that are
fantastic
okay so I thought that was just like an
interesting moment to frame some of this
like you there you have a Doctor Who's
whatever he's a little overweight okay
so be it but he's basically telling you
he's addicted to junk food and he
doesn't take vitamins but here he is on
these shows and believe me he was all
over MSNBC and CNN and all The Usual
Suspects for three years basically
pushing vaccines on people and remember
remember all that time during covid why
we kept asking why why are they not
having more nutritionists on why are
they not having more fitness experts on
why are they telling people to stay at
home and not go outside and not get sun
so you get some vitamin D take more care
of yourself instead they're telling
everyone stay at home order in get fat
like none of it made any sense and here
you have a guy you know it's not to make
it about his diet specifically but it
that is connected to something right so
now I want to jump to another interview
uh that Rogan did a little bit after
that by a guy by the name of Andrew
huberman and he's a neuroscientist and
tenured associate professor in the
department of neurobiology and
Psychiatry and Behavioral Sciences at
Stanford University School of Medicine
and here he is talking about how crazy
and sort of maddening it was to have
potez on his podcast
like if you want to optimize your health
yeah supplements are very beneficial
very beneficial but I think for you and
me it's a it's a it's a duh but I think
for a lot of people out there and so
they they seem to think that there's
something unique about prescription
drugs that is makes them better than
supplements well that's because they've
been lied to I mean that's that's the
real problem is that the corporations
who control these prescription drugs and
sell these prescription drugs and sell
advertising on television have got it
into people's heads that's why it was
maddening when I had Peter Hotes on the
podcast and he was talking to me about
the importance of vaccination I said do
you exercise how do you eat do you take
vitamins and there was Zero going on
with him he goes on walks occasionally I
mean positions or something junk food he
wasn't taking vitamins so okay that was
obviously Rogan uh talking about the
frustration not huberman but you see the
point there there's this odd asymmetry
between oh there are things you can do
for yourself that are within your
capacity as a human that actually don't
cost a ton of money in some cases no
money like take a walk and get some
sunshine fish oil supplements you know
these are not expensive things basic
vitamins
a multivitamin Etc but we just did not
talk about all of these things so now
why am I telling you all this why are we
rehashing all of this covid stuff
knowing that many of you are red pilled
already on this that's a pill you should
be taking the red pill well now let's
get into what happened over the weekend
here is a tweet from Dr Peter hotez this
is what sparked the entire thing
Spotify has stopped even sort of trying
to stem Joe Rogan's vaccine
misinformation it's really true Adam
Merlin just awful and from all the
online attacks I'm receiving after this
absurd podcast it's clear many actually
believe this nonsense now the the Absurd
podcast he's referring to of course is
RFK on Rogan now remember he's also
claiming that Rogan is spreading
misinformation on Spotify but he had no
problem going on Rogan's show to say
whatever it is that he wanted to say so
anyway now we're going to go into a
whole bunch of tweets here Rogan then
responded to that
and and this is really where the thing
caught fire he said Peter if you claim
what RFK Jr is saying is misinformation
I am offering you a hundred thousand
dollars to the charity of your choice if
you're willing to debate him on my show
with no time limit Hotes then responded
to that Joe you have my cell my email
and I'm always willing to speak to you
then Rogan responded this is a
non-answer I challenged you publicly
because you publicly quote tweeted and
agreed with that dog Vice article
if you're really serious about what you
stand for you now have a massive
opportunity for a debate that will reach
the largest audience a discussion like
this has ever had if you think someone
else is better qualified please suggest
that person so you can see this thing
was starting to percolate then Elon Musk
got involved and this is where it
started sort of breaking into a new uh
level Elon then responded to Joe and
said he's afraid of public debate
because he knows he's wrong then Peter
hotez responded to Rogan Joe if you are
serious about addressing vaccines and
the fact that 200 000 unvaccinated
Americans needlessly perished during our
awful delta ba1 covid waves including 40
000 in our state of Texas because they
fell victims to vaccine disinformation I
want to have that discussion then Rogan
responded again I'm going to ask you
very clearly are you willing to debate
Robert Kennedy Jr on my podcast then
this guy Tom Nichols who's a staffer at
the Atlantic I think he's occasionally
on MSNBC he responded with this and you
can now start to see how the lines were
being drawn on what side people are on
uh he said no medical professional
should ever agree to do this never it
elevates the conspiracy guide demeans
the medical professional and will only
convince the Kooks out there that Jay
that RFK is right because a real doctor
took the time to debate him never debate
a conspiracy theorist ah
Rogan saw that and Rogan said that would
be a great suggestion if you could
assure that the industry you were
representing wasn't completely captured
by heartless monsters who have a history
of some of the biggest criminal fines in
human history because their deceptions
has cost hundreds of thousands of people
their lives it would be a great
suggestion if the industry you were
defending didn't occasionally look at
humans beak didn't occasionally look at
human beings as an opportunity to
generate insane wealth regardless of the
tragic consequences but you can't do
that so maybe it would be a good idea to
have a debate okay so now you
can sort of see what's going on here
we're going to do a little more in just
a sec but you can see what's going on
here Rogan is basically saying hey
hotels you're basically calling for me
to be banned from Spotify even though
I've had you on my show to present your
side and then I had RFK on my show to
present the other side so let's just
let's just debate and then you can see a
whole bunch of people because this Tom
Nichols guy wasn't the only one a whole
bunch of people Maddie Hassan from MSNBC
and others basically like no you don't
debate conspiracy theorists and this is
what they've done with everybody right
they label you a conspiracy theorist or
you're a racist or a bigot or a
homophobic transphobed so that they
don't have to debate you right that's
basically how everything has operated
for the last couple years and I think
enough people have now seen that that
then this thing really started to catch
fire
so what was next here then I decided to
get involved I I felt could we add a
little humor to this thing uh so I said
this I said I will donate a hundred
thousand dollars for Peter Hotes to
fight Anthony fauci to the death in
Thunderdome Joe Rogan can do
play-by-play and there of course is the
recently passed oh I loved her so much
Tina Turner as Auntie from uh
Thunderdome remember where you are this
is Thunderdome death is listening now
then uh many people took that tweet
seriously many thousands of people
thought I was being serious about that
putting a hundred thousand dollars into
this thing and this guy Chief nerd who
sort of looks at well what's going on
online and you know tells people okay
here are the things the cool things
happening online right now uh he tweeted
this out
and this is where it started getting
nutty the Peter Hotes RFK Jr charity
debate pot is up to eight hundred sixty
thousand dollars please add any other
contributions I missed in the comments
there was the hundred thousand from
Rogan this guy Bill Ackerman threw in
150. uh Reuben report was good for a
hundred although mine involved involved
a rusty chainsaw and I'm fairly certain
it's illegal in every state but Florida
uh Patrick Bet David my buddy threw in a
hundred uh this Kirsch guy threw in 100
we got 50 from Jason Howerton uh Jason
kalanekanakis from uh from the all in
pod 10 grand and 250 uh from this guy
Nick mugal and that he referenced all
the tweets there then as if that wasn't
all crazy enough so these are the rest
of them I think we're being serious they
were going to throw the money and again
mine was about the Thunderdome I mean we
were talking about a guy with a rusty
screwdriver going after a guy with an ax
in there on trapeze it's a whole
situation then Andrew Tate we've talked
about Andrew Tate on the show Andrew
Tate got involved he wrote this
I'll add 500k but I also want to State a
lot of the Nerds who are anti-vaxx now
were total coveted at the start
a lot of them even took the vaccine so I
wanted to clear that up because as you
guys know I did not take the vaccine I
did not force anyone to take the vaccine
I tweeted this out and this was one of
my favorite moments from all of the
covet Insanity I said for the record I
never got vaxed never asked any of my
employees to get vacs and move my family
and two companies out of California
during covid I also had this fine moment
on Fox
are you a good decent citizen are you
vaccinated
it's nobody's business whether I'm
vaccinated that's like me asking you the
last time you got laid I mean it's just
irrelevant okay then that was a pretty
sweet moment and nobody wants to know
the last time she got laid uh Jordan
Peterson got involved too he retweeted
me he said he'll throw in a hundred
thousand dollars if they fight naked so
if you wanted to see Anthony fauci and
Peter hotez fight naked that's another
hundred grand from Jordan Peterson
anyway the internet was just bubbling
with this like it was the thing online
okay so then yesterday
uh yeah it had 2017 energy like when the
internet when Twitter was fun and cool
and people were fighting and offering to
debate each other there was something
happening everyone could kind of feel it
because it was like oh all the
artists and the censorious people and
the people who get wrong everything
they're kind of being exposed in real
time and you can see how they operate
they say things they don't want to be
challenged then they give you reasons
why they can't talk to you and all of
these other things anyway hotels then
last night went on the televised mental
institution MSNBC on this real whack job
that you know and it's hard to pick
who's the craziest whack job yes the
craziest whack job at MSNBC is what's
her name uh what the hell is her name
Joy Reed but this guy's on the list too
this is Medi Hassan so Hotes went on
Medi Hassan's show to explain why he
would not debate RFK Jr
I don't know if you've agreed to debate
or not my advice is not to and people
might find that surprising because I
wrote a book about debate but I just
think there's a time and a place for a
debate I don't think a historian of
World War II should debate a holocaust
denier I think just you know that's
that's my analogy here like I don't
think these debates between experts and
cranks do anything other than Elevate
the cranks
well you're absolutely right I mean
there are certain things you debate I
understand what a debate about 18th
century Enlightenment philosophy is and
and debating Rousseau and Bishop Bishop
Barkley I understand what political
debates are but in science we don't
typically do debates what we do is we
write scientific papers we present our
findings in front of a critical audience
of our peers to solicit their their
input and suggestions but it's you've
got one doesn't typically debate science
maybe the one-off discussion of
Evolution versus creationism and that
sort of thing but that's not what we do
in science Robert Kennedy Jr is an
environmental lawyer I wouldn't expect
him to debate me on environmental law
and I don't see why anyone would think
that you would debate
you know it's really bizarre you can
only talk to or debate people who are
experts in a specific thing you can't
have debates with people who have fairly
decent knowledge to say the least about
certain things that maybe not may not be
their pure area of expertise also the
way Mary Hassan who is just such an
awful propagandist at a giant Network
the way he frames it that that RFK Jr is
the conspiracy theorist and the crank
well if that was true and now that this
thing had sort of become much bigger
because of all the money that was
offered to be thrown in because the way
the whole internet was looking at it
maybe hotels could be like you know what
though in this case this thing does feel
like it has like a seminal teaching
moment and I'll go in there and debunk
some of the things he said by the way I
did watch the entire segment which is
very painful to watch anything on MSNBC
like a full segment of it at no point
did they debunk anything that he said
like why wouldn't you just do what we do
on this show every day think how easy it
would be if the truth was on their side
think how easy it would be for hotels to
do this literally from home or Medi
Hassan with his team how they could just
take Clips like we take them take the
quote-unquote lies and conspiracy
theorists and crank nonsense from RFK Jr
and then just show us the stats show us
the numbers tell us the truth show us
the experts who can counter it but of
course they don't do that they just
dismiss it he's a crank and then they
somehow go oh it's like debating a
Holocaust in Iron that's what they do
with everything so why are we also so
skeptical of the machine why are we
skeptical of their surrogates like this
mehdi Hassan guy and their big Pharma
shells like hotels well maybe maybe I
said maybe I'm just nuts but maybe it's
because of the severe
endless Ad nauseam lying that occurred
for the last three years from the top
down
which brings me to Anthony fauci RFK
told uh Rogan a little bit about the
time he first met Anthony fauci
2016 Donald Trump asked me to serve on a
vaccine safety commission and I agreed
to do it and I and he then ordered fauci
and Collins to meet with me and you know
Peter marks at FDA and all that so I had
meetings with all these guys so you know
I said to him Tony you've said been
telling people I'm a liar
when I say no vaccine has ever been none
of the mandated vaccines what they call
recommended they're actually mandated in
many of the states
I said none of them have ever been
tested against uh in a
placebo-controlled trial and a safety
test prior to licensing
and I said can you show me one
vaccine that has been subject to a safe
test show me one study that shows that
and he made it this show of looking
through a red will
they had brought in from NIH this big
tray full of file folders and he made a
show of kind of looking through that at
the time but he couldn't find whatever
he was looking for so then he said it's
back in NIH in Bethesda
and I'll send it to you well he never
did
so Aaron and I sued him sued HHS and and
said show us one study that's ever been
done on you know pre-licensing safety
testing for vaccines
and after a year of stone stonewalling
they finally gave us a letter and said
we don't have any
does that guy strike you as a crank and
a conspiracy theorist does that story
ring true to you or not did he actually
do the lawsuit yeah he did we checked
do you get it do you get it
now watch as we very smoothly move into
a wonderful compilation of Anthony fauci
lying about everything
but they're really criticizing science
because I represent science
if you're vaccinated you really don't
need to worry about
getting it in a way that's serious or
transmitting it
that is true that is correct Chris
they're totally to protect you
completely against infection and the
chances are very likely that you'll not
be able to transmit it to other people
the wrist is extremely low of
transmitting it to anybody else full
stock senated people are clearly capable
of transmitting the infection
[Music]
when you're in the middle of an outbreak
wearing a mask might make people feel a
little bit better if people are not
wearing masks then maybe we should be
mandating it I often myself wear two
masks and I'm quoting you now at the
population level masks work at the
margins maybe 10 to hear that they only
work at the margins maybe 10 would make
a lot of people ask okay then why was I
wearing a mask you're really attacking
not only Dr Anthony fauci you're
attacking science when you say that this
is going to go away tomorrow like magic
when you know that there's no chance
it's going to just disappear we hope
this just goes away Burns itself out
so my question is why weren't you
straight with the American people about
this to begin with so the bottom line is
it's a guesstimate I gave a range it
seemed in that quote to suggest that you
were basing your uh your recommendation
on polling and what people could accept
is that not what you meant
[Music]
no I mean it's a bit of that guys this
video goes on for about five minutes we
we shortened it for the purposes of the
show today but that thing I am the
science it is literally Emperor
Palpatine in Revenge of the Sith I am
the Senate it's treason then these
people are completely out of control one
more on fauci here because this was
early on in covid you remember a guy by
the name of Don Lemon does that ring a
bell to any of you guys I don't remember
exactly who he was I guess he was on CNN
uh here he is uh hosting Anthony fauci
and fauci's not happy because Trump
refuses to issue a lockdown order faster
and here in the United States we are
still not doing what we need to do to
fight this deadly virus because of a
complete lack of leadership the
president still won't issue a nationwide
stay-at-home order Dr Anthony fauci
bluntly saying this tonight
I don't understand why that's not
happening as you said you know the
tension between federally mandated
versus states rights to do what they
want is something I don't want to get
into but if you look at what's going on
in this country I just don't understand
why we're not doing that we really
should be I love that clip because
obviously lemon is long since gone from
CNN lemon had no knowledge whether
lockdowns should work or not lockdowns
were based on absolutely nothing and we
now know that the cost of lockdown not
only economically but psychologically
and everything else has been absolutely
disastrous on young people's Mental
Health on all the small businesses that
were closing everything else and there's
fauci now Trump I've been somewhat
critical of trump over the last couple
months right but Trump was trying to
keep the states open for the most part
and he did make some mistakes with this
he was trying to leave it in the hands
of the state then there are moments like
when Georgia wanted to open up early and
he was going against it so Trump is not
and then Trump of course did Operation
War speed so he's not you know he is not
bloodless on this thing but in this case
fauci was upset that he wasn't locking
down more even though again there is no
end time hotels come after me on this
one there is no scientific evidence
whatsoever that lockdowns were going to
work or ever have worked now you might
go Dave why why is it that these people
get to go on these programs all the time
and lie why do the lies always go in One
Direction why is it that only one set of
person and people get D platformed but
the people who lie over
and over and over and over again
why is it that they're always on these
television shows
well you know what it might just be that
pharmaceutical companies are paying for
these TV shows hot diggity dog
20 America is brought to you by Pfizer
CBS healthwatch sponsored by Pfizer
Anderson Cooper 360. brought to you by
Pfizer ABC News Nightline brought to you
by Pfizer making a difference brought to
you by Pfizer CNN tonight brought to you
by Pfizer early start brought to you by
Pfizer Friday night on Aaron Burnett out
front brought to you by Pfizer This Week
With George Stephanopoulos is brought to
you by Pfizer this weather report
brought to you by Pfizer today's
countdown to the Royal Wedding is
brought to you by Pfizer and now with
CBS sports update brought to you by
Pfizer Meet the Press data download
brought to you by this portion of CBS
This Morning sponsored by Pfizer on how
to find the hidden sugars in the
American Family diet sponsored by Pfizer
happy
I know you know it right I know you know
it but a whole bunch of people don't
know it they refuse to see it and even
when you show them things like that they
still don't want to see it one more clip
of RFK on Rogan they started talking
about why Pharma and the government and
the media are all tied up together in
this endless bukaki of insanity that is
being sprung upon all of us
they are able to dictate content on
television so they can dictate content
on the you know on the local and on
YouTube yeah of course yeah
that
that's a terrifying thing and it's so
deeply interwoven
the the question that I would have to
you is like how do you untangle that how
you do
things at a time and I you know I'm
gonna go in there
there's no more advertising on TV now
FDA needs to implement that through the
regulatory process but I also know how
the regulatory process works and I know
how to hasten it I know how to make it
work faster for the American people so
you know I
um I know I you know I'm looking forward
to doing this I'm looking forward to
telling after you hey you're not taking
Pharma money anymore
we are not governed by the FDA that is
what I think RFK Jr understands and they
put money into all of these programs
which then push their propaganda and
then they also and this is the key part
they also have connections and the
government has connections as we now
know because of the Twitter files with
all of the big tech companies right so
not only do they push out and sponsor
propaganda on mainstream media but then
for the people on YouTube
etc etc or just you at home just being
like you know I did see this study it's
a little outside of what mainstream meat
I'm going to put that on Twitter bang
it's gone
oh your YouTube channel is deleted etc
etc uh it's a double edged sword it's
not a double edge so it's a double it's
a double prong sword right a
double-edged sword would be hitting you
both ways this thing is pronged both
ways we're gonna we're gonna uh sponsor
propaganda and we're also gonna take out
the people that are pushing against the
propaganda so the point is that the
media the pharmaceutical companies and
the government are all financially
incentivized to propagate propagandize
and censor you now I want to bring this
back to one other thing that happened to
me at the height of covid because when
again looking back these things all
makes sense this is from Fox News in
July of 2021. political commentator Dave
Rubin is firing back at Twitter after
the tech giant locked him out of his
account for allegedly violating its
policy on spreading coronavirus
misinformation everything I said in that
tweet is true Reuben told Fox News in an
interview every single thing that I said
in that tweet was true and this is a
complete continuation of silencing any
sort of dissent anyone that questions
the The Narrative is in a lot of trouble
when it comes to Big Tech and we better
fight it because we're running out of
time the tweet that landed the Reuben
report host in hot water was in response
to the Biden administration's evolving
response to the pandemic they want a
federal vaccine mandate for vaccines
which are clearly not working as
promised just weeks ago people are
getting and transmitting covid despite
the facts plus now they're prepping us
for booster shots a sane society would
take a pause we do not live in a sane
Society Reuben tweeted Thursday evening
according to Twitter however that tweet
was violated that tweet violated its
policy on spreading misleading and
potentially harmful information related
to covid-19 they are lying Reuben
reacted on Twitter so yes I was right
that was weeks after just literally
weeks after Joe Biden said you will not
get nor transmit covid if you get the
vaccine it obviously wasn't working so I
warned on that I warned that mandates
were coming and booster shots were
coming all those things happen in the
fall after that and I was censored and
you go okay well there is a connection
and they're sponsoring mainstream media
pushing vaccines and at the end at the
same time
they're working with tech to silence the
people that actually are pushing against
it okay Robert F Kennedy actually was
another person who was severely censored
during covet I thought this tweet was
interesting from Rumble during covet
Robert F Kennedy was primarily heard on
Rumble no other large platform could
claim they did more than Rumble during
covid for free expression we will hold
the line for free speech always and then
another interesting thing happened
related to RFK Jr and we see this all
the time you know when someone starts
gaining momentum the system comes
crashing down at you right this is Rogan
has lived through many versions of this
right you start getting too influential
next thing you know they just want to
take you out it's what's happening to
RFK right now Dan bongino posted this on
Twitter uh Mike Tyson post-censored
interview with RFK Jr on Rumble after
YouTube censorship yes that's right uh
Mike Tyson boxer Mike Tyson who's
actually become a sort of interesting
cultural critic he he interviewed RFK
they took it off YouTube so he put it on
Rumble so now I want to end with one
thing that will get us a little bit out
of the day-to-day minutia because I do
think we can all get lost in that it's
important to know this stuff but as
always you have to go ahead and you have
to figure out a way to pill for a little
sanity into your own life go ahead and
live your life as you see fit and
protect your family and all that and
know that there's all these things
there's all these problems but what can
you do in the mix of it it's not just
that RFK is going to save you it's not
just that Ron DeSantis is going to save
you or that Donald Trump is going to
save you
uh RFK Junior's uncle
John F Kennedy knew a little something
about that and he knew a little
something about what your role in Saving
this thing was all about
America
ask not
what your country can do for you ask
what you can do for your country
[Music]
that's it
that's it the government big Tech big
Pharma big media all of those things
they are not looking out for you they
are actually actively I would say going
after you but what you can do and this
is what I say about DeSantis all the
time I don't worship politicians but
when someone gets out there and does the
right thing I think it's incumbent on
you as a decent Citizen and as a decent
human being to help them along the way I
think it's incumbent on us for whatever
my political disagreements on say
climate change or guns might be with RFK
Jr and we're getting them on the show
soon we'll discuss it it's incumbent on
me and maybe on you to defend him right
now imagine this imagine if RFK Jr right
now was the Democrat nominee for
president or let's say it wasn't going
to be Biden right so Biden gets out of
the way they figure out what they have
to do with Kamala and it's that guy now
it's not going to be but imagine if it
was and then imagine it was Ron DeSantis
on the other side and we had a robust
debate about the role of government but
but people who could agree on certain
things right and then we had a debate on
what direction we want to go in and are
these people of an age are they of a
certain degree of Competency do they
have a pedigree that that is worthy of
them being the president of the United
States states the chief executive of the
United States man
that would be healthy I don't think
we're going to get fully there on the
Democrat side I think we might get there
on the Republican side we shall see uh
but guys it is Monday which means that
it's me Monday over at the
reubenreport.locals.com community here's
what I posted this morning I got hairy
legs hi I'm Joe Biden and of course that
is the elderly man pretending to be
president and it's the incapacitated man
pretending to be senator from
Pennsylvania John fetterman uh we got a
post game show for you right now at
reubenreport.locals.com my full
interview with author really great
thinker Roger we did it live on location
in Budapest Hungary uh that is up right
now across platforms we leave you and if
you need to mute this for the 45 seconds
till we get to the post game show I
don't blame you because you've seen it
before but it felt right to end with
when we talk about corporate collusion
and propagandists and people who sell
out and a set of people who want to
inject you with things even though they
have no freaking idea what's in them
and people who are just generally on fun
funny and just really unpleasant and
shouldn't even be on television and
thankfully I don't think this guy's on
TV right now because the writers strike
here's Stephen Colbert singing and
demeaning himself about vaccines goodbye
[Music]
let's see
[Applause]
[Music]
vaccine
[Applause]
[Music]